and welcome everybody to another YouTube
hangout super excited to be here with
you and my special guest of the day mr.
Gary Vaynerchuk he is the author of the
askgaryvee book I'm gonna link it up in
the description below if you guys to
check out he's eating something at the
moment where he eaten Gary uh English
peas I love them so much
with with the skin or it goes no um but
sometimes I'll bite them and like kind
of break them in with me to my teeth you
know I love it
Gary also ronzi askgaryvee show on
YouTube and the daily V show Gary's
channel is the only business channel
besides mine that I want to watch every
single video of so you gotta check it
out
it's very nice that's very nice thank
you about runs vaynermedia though the
world's fastest growing did you know
media agency it's gotta be up you know
obviously I don't really know exactly
what's going on out there so I don't
think fair but if there's not a lot of
agencies that have have grown from 30 to
600 people to from 3 to 100 million
revenue in four years so it's definitely
one of them I love it and the man is a
practitioner everything he talks about
he actually does he hustles it out to
the nth degree so Gary great to have you
man thank you brother
I really appreciate it now I wasn't
kidding when I said yours is the only
channel besides mine that I want to
watch every video but I'm kind of pissed
I'm pissed because when I watch videos
normally I'm doing something else and
when yours comes on I feel like I'm
always missing something when I'm
multitasking so I got a pause and rewind
and do it again so the only thing I can
do when I watch your show is work out
and so I'm still like in February
catching up to your videos because I
don't want to miss the stuff that
happens so I'm still like going through
the book launch just early days but
thank you for putting out such awesome I
really appreciate that in that's super
flattering now we first connected in
2010 I don't remember this I made a line
of famous entrepreneur trading cards and
they asked you who is your favorite
famous entrepreneur and you said Vince
McMahon I got a right here s the Vince
McMahon card and on the back I remember
that song
Wolvie Dupree the free healthy garyvee
and you wrote 2000-2010 storytelling is
the most important backbone of marketing
and once you scale good storytelling
you're in business forever you know
listen one of the great things I'm sure
you probably feel this way to the fact
that our great great great great
grandkids are gonna be able to watch
this they're watching this right now
like 137 years from now this is being
watched what you and I are doing right
now and to me things like that where you
know I start talking about storytelling
six years ago before it's like the
buzzword you know those are things that
that I'm proud of I like being right
historically I think that you know the
last couple years a lot of things have
fall in my way because people are
starting to realize that I've been
correct about where things are going
quite a bit and and it's been a nice
narrative but you're right I do value my
practitioner ship and so you know Vince
is still hustling I like people that put
in the work and and that's what I want
to focus on let's talk quickly about
hustle and motivation I know it's a it's
a whole chapter in the book on hustle
you don't like being called the
motivational speaker I know like you
kind of rejected that mantra you could
make a lot of money doing the speaking
doing the tours and what my question is
you know I know you're in the attention
game you want to be able to attention is
when you go type in Gary Vaynerchuk on
YouTube the first word that pops up
after Nina and the autosuggest is
motivation there's a lot of the time
there's a lot of need for it I know you
like the 5149 right you want to give
give give these people could all come
back and help you with all your big
project is attention like people are
striving for it but yeah I don't want to
do I'm just curious why not so I think
you clearly have a lot of contacts I
mean I think you're going to understand
this um so a and I think you know this
I've been giving for the last year a lot
more motivational stuff than I did for
the prior three or four years so a I'm
doing it I just don't want to be a
motivational speaker because I'm quite
proud that I actually am a practitioner
businessman but I'm very aware that I'm
motivational you know like I'm not
confused I mean it's a I got very lucky
I'm
thankful that the way I communicate
strikes people some humbled and I love
it but there's just a lot of people that
are motivational speakers that do
lowest-common-denominator marketing are
trying to very frankly rip people off
and I don't think it's the most
comfortable place for me to be
positioned for me it's my own selfish
Watsa needs everybody watching right now
gets to decide if I'm a motivational
speaker or not I just I just think I'm a
businessman who happens to be
motivational yeah and you're big on
self-awareness and it's like common
theme over and over and over again how
can people find their own self-awareness
what advice you have for someone who's
like struggling to figure what they want
to do I don't know I've you know I hate
that I can't answer this question but
I'm not enough of a scientist or or a
practitioner in trying to really figure
out one's us want how to help one find
their self-awareness I can tell you it
is a gift that if you have you should
cherish and I do think that listening so
even I think one thing that's really
good is I take all my comment like you
know I like to say I don't care what
anybody says
and I care what everybody says meaning I
read all my comments all of them
Facebook YouTube Twitter you know you
know snapchat Instagram like I
understand what people think about me
how they consume me at first if it's the
first time they're soon no we got
disconnected it was like in the story we
got disconnected we'll see we get them
back on thank you guys for the comments
I wasn't paying attention to them yet if
you guys have a question that you need
to have answered like one question let
me know what you think in the comments
and we'll see
I like those what about comparison Tim
Ferriss who has a 4-hour work week and
then Gary's message is all about the
hustle and like not working anywhere
close to 4-hour workweek so we can ask
him that but let me help
I won't try to get him back on he has
the link he was joining from his phone
in New York
city Alex Alex is Alec Alec is happy
that was his question asking about
balance family and work do you feel your
hustle message is clear enough or does
it confuse people I like it I'm just
going to write them a quick message let
them know that I got cut out Gary might
be in the middle of the story they
realize that he got cut it let's do it
up boom Gary
Eric you got is connected right bro send
it off you never know what's going to
happen on the live stream are you guys
like an act Alex I like this question or
workweek versus the US a--
you ever missing gary except for in the
story
i'll make sure to ask it again i'll make
sure we ask it again when you get him
back on he was a joining for his phone
so i don't know if his phone just lost
battery or what happened but we're in a
roll
elsa joining it was a good story to
start there we go there we go there we
go back he's bad they were loving the
self-awareness store and like what
happened I'm back so I'm not sure what
happened um so uh the punchline is you
know you've got to take the feedback if
somebody says your videos are great take
that and you feel good when somebody
says your videos are wack or you don't
have good editing skills Evan right like
you've got to take that seriously - like
if somebody says they don't like my
cursing I can't disregard them I have to
understand that's real and so I just
don't think I'm great enough basically
Evan honestly very seriously
I just live life the following way right
look I know I'm like I don't have
attention I know people like me I know
I've won I know I've made money I know
predicted things I know I'm a good guy
but at the end of the day if you can
deploy enough humility ego and bravado
to be open to people's feedback you can
start
really getting into a very good place
and that's that's one way I think about
it I will never look I plan on being the
guy I plan on winning the whole thing I
know the entrepreneurs that are ahead of
me now by billions of dollars if I think
I'm in a cat and I think I'm gonna do it
my way and I think my way is gonna be
very attractive from a legacy stamp in a
very nice and human way and uh fat and
and so but even when I reach that status
as like one of the guys one of the girls
one of the real pioneer entrepreneurs of
this generation I still plan on doing
this goddamn [ __ ] show and every
other show and take every selfie and
like I'm never going to get too big for
my bridges just don't know how and I
don't know why I would do that
what's winning the whole game what does
that mean you that out of all the
business people ever that enormous
amounts of people think that the way I
did it which was more noble done with
honey not vinegar done in a nice way uh
always grounded and then more
importantly the 83,000 people that got
to touch me along the way and especially
the 8,000 that got to interact with me
very closely that the closer you get to
me the more you think I'm a good human
being the more I've delivered on the
promise that my parents set me up with
DNA wise and the way they parented me I
want to go down as one of the most
successful entrepreneurs that did it not
the way Steve Jobs did it you know when
he delete old people to bring out the
best in them I want to be the reverse
that I did it in a way that brought
people value um and I did it for noble
and good reasons like you know I mean I
think one of the reasons we keep cutting
out sorry if I don't know everything and
I think one of the reasons you watch to
me or you edit and put out stuff on is
you know what I'm about to say
I put out
my best stuff I give away good stuff
that helps you like you watch me because
I'm bringing you value like like
tactical value and motivational value
like I'm obsessed with that I want to be
the guy that brought the most value to
the game I love it and so Steve Jobs is
the anti Garry for you look I listened
he changed the world
I don't know him I'm going I don't want
that to be my narrative right like I
don't know how much of that is truth
fiction lore but I definitely want to
belittle people to extract the most
value out of them right I mean like I
was hugging people and they did better
like like I was you know I listened for
a lot of people that are watching this
right now they confuse my kind of jay-z
aggressiveness right like if you really
look at my stuff and I assume because
you consume so much content then know
how to DJ it I don't know actually you
know what this is actually interesting
can I flip it on you like listen you
know from what I know and I don't know
that much I'm you know as you know I
don't consume that much media but I you
know that you've been making videos that
inspire people you're chopping up a lot
of different people I saw you know
through some searches and stuff of that
nature like what do you think is
different like why am y from all the
people it seems like you've middle how
many videos have you made of different
people like top 10 those kind of things
I've seen we have over 3,000 videos on
the channel good you know why me
versus all the other 1500 1700 2100
different individuals that make up those
3,000 videos why am i worth your time
and attention
yeah I think the points you make as well
as the amount of content that you're
putting out is different right so not
just the perspective than the point of
view but you're actually providing the
content where if you look at the other
people that were profiling it can be
really hard to get enough content on
them where yours is the opposite yours
like there's so much to dive through how
do we find the 10 where a lot of people
aren't great at doing interviews aren't
great at self-expression don't have the
self-awareness and just are a bad
of you and it just isn't a lot of
content on them and so you are pleasure
in that there's so much content that you
put in out a meaningful high-level stuff
that is interesting and helpful and
valuable that other people who are
running things at your level aren't
producing that kind of content and to me
what it speaks to is because uh and let
me tell you why it's happening I'm
patient enough to think I'm gonna get
mine so that all the time I give up like
right this second doing this you know
most guys and girls like me view that
the ROI of something like this inferior
to the level they're at and this is
instead of some business thing that can
make them a lot more money or progress
them I'm a willing to leave so much
money on the table during the journey
because the legacy I want is not to make
the most money cuz I'm gonna get mine
I've made enough money now it's really
cool
Brian bro you you feel this too I'm sure
do you know craziness to get emails
saying you've helped people's lives I'm
sure you do I get a thousand of them a
day you're crazy that is I hear you and
that's why I do it I get it it's a high
like I don't get the same I leave in a
five million dollar contract the other
day I don't get off on that not the same
way I get from a kiddin emails me and
says they're homeless and they were
[ __ ] sitting outside and somebody was
listening to one of my videos it caught
their attention
they figured out who I was by asking the
guy like the four years on you later
like you not crazy that is that's legacy
that's legacy I love it let's switch
gears to snapchat I know you're all in
on snapchat
I think you've brought more people on
the snapchat than anybody else you are
the snapchat marketing maven uh I've
always had a challenge with with stuff
that just disappears I like creating
stuff that lives forever like you
mentioned the top of the show that you
know 10 years people will still come
back and watch this video I hate the
idea of creating something and then poof
it's gone like the street artist writing
something down and then the rain washes
it away am i seeing it wrong or is it
just ok so what's what's I guess I
mention it there but I want like the
light lasting stuff well good do both
you can download this
or even upload them like you do a ton of
things and sure yeah I mean every
conversation you've ever had in life
disappears termo most television pre DVR
all television pre DVR day like yeah I
mean I think God and by the way not
everything has to do the same thing and
most of all the value of that attention
is extreme you know like people are just
gonna be they're just gonna happen you
know I'm a very big believer of like
look whether I like it or not it's gonna
be and so you know I forgot like you
that is building his brand as a curator
of content and I an excuse me if I'm
wrong with that that's just kind of how
I see it from afar so far like I don't
see how I don't see how how you can't
afford in my opinion to punt snapchat
it's gonna be too big so so to me it
starts with that religion right like if
you fully believe that right you know if
you fully believe that then that alone
in itself but yeah I mean like I mean I
think it's kind of cool oh sorry man I
don't know what's going on hello good
night you okay cool uh you know I I
think that um I think that there's gonna
be different genres of ways to
communicate and and if snapchat doesn't
work for you that's fine but I'm telling
you like a homie like just don't
disrespect it cuz it's gonna be a beast
okay
I'm yeah I get it I'm also not huge on
Instagram or doing a ton on Twitter or
Facebook
I just hate the business of things
disappearing I want the stuff I make to
last forever most of us read Instagram
you you making one-minute versions for
Instagram and being smart about hashtags
would blow up your [ __ ] okay
good advice write it down and you know
the good thing about advice is like look
you don't have to you've got like I
always think that people need like
people give me advice all the time I
completely disregard it like you do you
but like that's one man's point of view
you know I appreciate it um get back to
the book yeah so I mean this is coming
out or this is already out sorry and you
know selling like hotcakes
ah
bit of a selfish question for me so I'm
getting my book ready for December I'm
curious for you this is my first one
what what was the single most effective
thing you did in the marketing of this
book and what was the most surprisingly
effective one maybe that's the same
thing but like singer most effective and
most surprising in the promotion of this
book that worked out for you I think um
I think first of all if your books
coming out in December is it listed on
Amazon already then uh they're working
on it they're going to put it I'm with
penguin Random House got it so the
second the second you are having Amazon
you should start selling it like the
second like the number one rule is start
selling it as soon as you can like all
the people that are watching right now
right like they obviously care about you
and you should absolutely um
create it really the number one tactic
is selling early the number the real -
what I call tactics zero is provide more
value to the community than you're
asking for in return so what having
lunch with you skypes whatever you know
all those packages of by five by ten I
believe in those so much because
everybody wins right like you want to
sell ten books at a time and Sally
Thompson right now in Texas really wants
to spend two minutes with you on skype
right so I would give people access and
give them what they want I love it
impulse or so Instagram influencers
crushed yeah who is your or who are some
of the biggest people that can I haven't
seen your Instagram stuff I saw all your
book tour videos but who helped you on
the Instagram site oh it was just people
that have a thousand or four hundred or
49 or seventy-eight you know just asking
people that were fans to share it on
Instagram and just use hashtag book
review and you know they listen if
somebody has 89 fans and they say or
followers excuse me and say you know I
love this book if four of them buy it
that's meaningful like this isn't about
kim kardashian this is about kim
kardashian got it a whole bunch of
questions coming in from the audience
one around the hustle and the guy
basically just was reading your book and
was
in the Far workweek and yes feeling
confused is Alec about Hustle versus
like Tim who's maybe saying hey work
four hours a week and but Tim doesn't
say work four hours a week you know what
he says is be efficient I think I think
right and so I know Tim he's the best
and you just weren't like he's he's much
better at being efficient than I am
he loves systems he's way better at that
too like I think I love hard work
because I just think it's the cost of
entry right like Tim Ferriss works his
ass off now now we all can Evan flow and
have our balances and things that make
sure when your work is your love like it
is for me and others like that's a huge
win but I think alec has to figure it
out for himself right like whether you
you know what what what works for you
and I think for me hard work works for
other people they can't work 12 or 15
hours a day they just not physically
built that way or things that nature
mentally they'll wear out like you got a
do you you got to figure out your system
they both work and how did you find
yours you just just your DNA your
parents yeah I think I think hard work
is from what I've learned like work
being a workaholic is a learned behavior
my dad worked his face off my mom worked
her face off around the house like when
she raised us she didn't have like help
of any kind
she and we didn't do [ __ ] she like
picked up after us and everything like I
think I just saw I feel like my mom says
that me my dad and her all of us in my
family were all hard workers like we're
worker dogs you know some dogs are just
working like that's who we are and
that's who I am I'm so going back to
your parents in kind of the early days
when you're you know getting naps in
school and not doing well and kind of
punting it to do your own thing
yes and you know having the good fortune
to have a mom especially like you had
supporting you and giving you the
confidence that you have for people who
may not be as fortunate now and you
don't have that parent of support right
or or the opposite like the parents
saying you can't do this right
you can't go start that business or
that's such a stupid idea or you know
friends who don't believe in you like
just surrounded by haters yeah what
tell them like I got a dream but I'm
surrounded by haters everywhere then
you're not good enough if you're gonna
let other people dictate your outcome
like like you're just then you deserve
to lose like you can't blame anybody but
yourself I really believe that man like
I know I know I'm saying that super
nonchalantly while I'm eating English
peas but like I've like what what what
am I supposed to say like they were
right like being a victim is a losing
formula you know I mean II see like
being a victim that's a losing formula
like okay and like I don't give you
trophies like nobody's walking around
with like like badges like oh I was a
victim like like let's call it what it
is nobody gives a [ __ ] like we all have
problems everybody's got problems like
and some people have way bigger problems
than others and there is racism and
sexism and and just all sorts of issues
in the world the problem is at the end
of the day nobody cares and you have to
care about yourself and so it you know a
lot of people think like whining about
it does something like nobody cares
about my problems like and and nobody
cared about my problems when I had
nothing so nothing changes like just
when I say nobody cares about my
problems like yeah okay like you go to a
public cool I got problems like the
whole world is on my shoulders like I
strat like I'm the last line of defense
for everything in my world so family
family members pressure all day but you
know P Diddy was right biggie was right
more money more problems like it's not
more problems it's different problems
they become different problems la you
know some people can't make rent that's
a different problem the problem is
though is nobody cares like especially
if you're unfortunate you know it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy if you are
surrounded by negative people and people
that drag you down and they're the ones
that you're complaining to they want you
to be miserable misery loves company
you know that's that
so it's the environment like about
changing your environment right like
going to somewhere where you are around
people who are like I think you do that
for a lot of people people watch my
videos for that too like the only the
only ones in their lives who actually
give them hope and belief because
everybody around them is just tearing
them down yeah I'm pumped that I can do
that and I'm sure you feel the same way
and like I
that's that drives a lot of my content
I'm excited about that like I want to
bring people value like I want I want to
be you know what's funny actually you
got me to say something I haven't said I
sent to my mom the other day I feel so
guilty that my mom was so awesome
that I wanted that I that I want to be
that for other people hmm you know like
I feel like I got so lucky that I almost
have to give back to everybody and play
that role and I can't to the level my
mom did for me but if I can play a
little bit of that role to the market to
the people that are watching right now
well then I've accomplished something
like if there's somebody right now in
the chat I can't see the chat who like
like can tangibly feel like something
that I put out in the world affected
them in a positive manner that feels
good and I almost feel like it's my
destiny because I have to pay back that
that's what happened to me and I got
lucky that person was my mom for me
so so pain she with your mom's gonna be
a real legacy yeah I think that's
probably right no question I mean like
there you know I you know you've heard
me you know I love talking about legacy
like it seems like there's about 47
things that are now my legacy and that's
right right which is like for every what
you and that's true that like honestly
at some level um everybody who's
watching right now or anybody who ever
watches and I bring value to like my
legacy my reputation will be different
for everybody right like it'll be
different for everybody and you know I
like that it's a very um
it's equally a very humble thing as it
is a vanity thing for me like I pull it
both sides of the extremes on this issue
like I am I want the vanity of like the
attention in the admiration and the
selfies on the street but I also um
I'm just so grateful and thankful and
humbled that I can make an impact on
people's lives I love it well I know
we're bumping up against the clock
Gary super appreciate the time but those
you're watching you can check out
askgaryvee book we'll link it up below
thanks a lot man thanks to spending your
Friday afternoon with us thank you
brother I wish you nothing but the best
I wish everybody's watching nothing but
the best awesome thanks man take care
bye bye